[Musique]
dans notre séquence ping pong ce soir je
reçois catherine breillat qui va
répondre à une critique de pierre
vavasseur du parisien à propos de son
dernier roman on verra ce qu'il en est
de l'appellation bad love catherine
breillat bonsoir bonsoir
alors avec vertige ou s'est aperçu que
l'homme fasse il avait 40 ans exactement
c'est assez étonnant alors toute une
carrière entre cet homme facile qui a
été un événement en 68 il est sorti au
moment de mai 68 je crois oui et est
aujourd'hui donc de nos quelques
quelques repères que ce soir au mans 198
avec rocco siffredi ça fait quand même
pas mal de mémoire qui élimine la
famille des familles un débat non
simulés bord dont on a parlé en 2000
votre vos prises de position quand
virginie despentes avec ben et moi avait
risqué d'être interdit il ya beaucoup de
gens qui pensent que je suis l'auteur de
d'accord oui on vous attribue beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup toute démission tout
ce qui selon vous la tribune voilà donc
et donc vous avez aussi un événement
personnel il une attaque cérébrale qui
est vous avez écrit corps amoureux en
2006 j'ai fait avant avant mais
curieusement ni dans fut avant il ya
comme une sorte de prémonition un moment
jeudi même si je suis sur un fauteuil
roulant
je ferai des films j'écrirais alors
aujourd'hui on se rencontre pour bad
love alors c'est un roman je sais que
vous n'aimez pas trop le terme et disons
un peu ce que l'on va trouver à
l'intérieur on dit souvent c'est la
rencontre improbable de deux aides qui
n'aurait pas dû se rencontrer qui vont
vous apercevrez oui mais on
je vais vous dire ce que l'on délaisse
coop une fleur en contrepartie de ces
luttes et le fils au télescope
c'est que en se rencontrant même
ensemble soi même on se connaît pas tu
très dans le connais toi toi même
et finalement en se rencontrant ils ne
connaissent pas l'autre qui demeure
toujours un mystère mais et qu'il
éclaircisse leur propre mystère a eu un
effet miroir
or bien écouter on va maintenant voir ce
que pierre vavasseur à penser de vos
textes et comme vous connaissez le pensé
ou dit voilà on est dans la distraction
est en tout cas lançons le sujet avec la
critique de pierre vasseur
bonsoir catherine la belle langue je
vous arrête tout de suite parce que dans
la tête de votre article vous me nommez
breillat breillat pas brillante
alors breillat pas brillante c'est un
jeu de mot avec le patronyme un jeu de
mots douteux qui je trouve ou
décridibilise d'anglais alors c'était
dans le parisien faut signaler que par
isabelle le parisien c'est pas le truc
avançons je suis votre travail mine de
rien depuis très longtemps je trouve que
vous êtes quelqu'un de tout à fait
calqué sur l'époque voire d kalck est
certes bon il le suit mon travail depuis
très longtemps mais je crois pas parce
que c'est mine de rien ça vous avez
remarqué cette formule oui oui mine de
rien ça veut dire quoi qui le suit ce
qu'on dit mon travail c'est et le suit
même à la lettre bon d'écouter la suite
de sa chronique savez sans doute le
talon de jouer avec cette époque et de
pousser le curseur très loin qui oui
très loin en arrière je dirais j'ai
toujours dit que j'avais 20 ans d'
avance et que ça c'est une souffrance au
boulot on vous le fait payer quand on a
vingt ans d'avancé aux opportunistes se
disant je laisse parler
non vraiment pas terrible je trouve ce
livre du haut de ma grandeur si je peux
vivre un taux ridicule et or ça m'embête
de dire ça mais j'ai eu beaucoup de mal
à le lire jusqu'au bout parce que j'ai
abandonné plusieurs fois tout près
d'abandonner alors s'il abandonnait
plusieurs fois d'abord s'ils
connaissaient mon travail serait que
c'est toujours comme un fil tendu et un
fil tendu
si vous le coupez plusieurs fois vous
voyez bien que ça tombe par terre
par contre le livre est très très court
où il est court et pousser les rangs des
buts et on ne peut pas le dire dans la
continuité parce que j'aime le soutien
et la première question que je me suis
posée c'est mais pourquoi léo cher un
laisser faire
pourquoi et vous cher pourquoi
s'intéresser à ce que mon éditeur c'est
la deuxième fois comblé mais qui demande
directement à mon éditeur
il se trouve que je vous ai donné le
livre qu'une heure après une demi-heure
après lui parce qu'il est il sait lire
plus vite
il me téléphonait en me disant je veux
absolument publié diaries est publié en
quinze jours de chose de très semblable
à votre cette absence de steve servir
une intense de contenu cette histoire
vous la traitez un peu par dessus la
jambe
j'ai l'impression c'est à dire c'est
très facile de faire en sorte d'aller
retour comme ça entre deux personnages
s'allie pas avec une certaine vulgarité
c'est ça qui me gêne beaucoup
la bulgarie tube l'a toujours reproché
ici c'est la même chose qu'on m'a dit
sur 36 fillette que septaine j'étais
d'une vulgarité ce qui fait que quand il
a été en réalité sélectionné au festival
de new york anne 20 ans comme seul film
français
le président d'unifrance film s'était
déplacé spécialement pour dire que
j'étais pas représentatif du cinéma
français et aux états unis gèlent
étagères entières
il ya que moi et bresson avec mes films
et tous les films que j'ai pas en france
vous avez pas dans le bon goût français
non mais soutine et vulgaire met le
doigt dans la chair et moi je l'aimais
soutine quand j'étais tout petit
et bien quand on faisait nos athlètes
bacon je préfère être bacon que marie
laurencin alors mais n'en déplaise à ce
monsieur je ne suis pas marié laurencin
voilà ça c'est clair c'est clair qu'on
ménage il ya ce personnage s'appelle
louis qui nous intéresse sa mère qui qui
a pas de comment dire de force qui
rentrent pas lui-même dans l'histoire
parce qu'il n'est pas invitée par la
metteur en scène des créatures à rentrer
dans cette histoire il ne rentre pas
dans cette histoire puisqu'il n'a pas
d'histoire
ce qui les attire ils sont tout le
contraire l'un de l'autre et pourtant
ils sont deux inconnus c'est à dire
qu'ils n'ont jamais eu d'histoire lui
avec une star elle avec un homme
finalement peu élégant qui lui dit aussi
sa vérité les stars on leur dit jamais
la vérité et c'est ça qui les rapproche
de l'inconnu avoir enfin un inconnu
sinon on a toujours le connu vous ne
faites pas exister ces deux personnages
et vous les faites pas exister parce que
vous zappez de l'un à l'autre à toute
allure jusqu'à une fin qui est bon et on
va le dire quand même tout ça c'est fini
lançant dans ce bain de sang on est on
est pas éclabousser moi j'aimerais bien
être éclaboussés peu un petit peu et
vous n'êtes pas avec la puissante
ça me gêne profondément parce que vous
êtes quelqu'un dont on est en droit
d'attendre autre chose
moi je trouve très important les gens
pourquoi parce que s'il écrit breillat
pas brillante c'est qu'il trouve
brillant d'habitude ou qu'il attend de
moi que je fasse ce que me ferait lui
même pas ce que c'est ça le problème des
gens qui attendent de vous quelque chose
or on sait qu'un artiste doit être
absolument inattendu
quitte à se prendre des claques alors
cette fin c'est pas un bain de sang
c'est l'espèce de montée quasi
inéluctable de cette histoire vers le
drame final vincent c'est une
c'est une mutilation je dirais ou là où
l'art la victime est l'appli faute forte
dans le rôle de la victime
parce que bon viviane parker c'est une
star mais elle a peur d'elle à des unes
des pulsions suicidaires extrêmement une
culture machiste aussi forte
même si en même temps elle est hot n y
ait qu elle écrase les autres mais ça ça
fait partie des gens au teint c'est
cette pulsion d'autodestruction voyons
ce que pierre levasseur a dit pour
conclure
déplace les lignes ayant un livre c'est
important pour ça aussi et vous êtes une
créatrice
vous êtes quelqu'un qui veut faire
bouger les choses vous pouvez pas vous
manquer ça eh bien résultat des courses
avec ce livre vous tombez à côté parce
que vous nous décevez moi ça moi je suis
très déçu c'est embêtant parce qu'on
attend des gens comme vous qui sont des
gens peut être courageux sans doute
courageux mêmes qui tirent pas peur du
repas froid aux yeux
mais arrêtez un peu quand même parce
qu'il ya un fatras un créateur veut pas
faire bouger les choses
ça c'est un sociologue une assistante
sociale
voyez encore il me prend pour une femme
quoi et je pense que on fait pas bouger
des choses on déplace les brutes où
passent les bornes et d'une certaine
manière trouve que j'ai passé les bornes
puisque je le déçois c'est aussi une
manière de passer les menottes
mais encore une fois on attend des gens
qu'on est tenté de nuire et les choses
beaucoup mieux on est enterrée vive
admire pas du tout et tu passes turquie
soit en tenir et détente et neveux sacré
mais enfin bon ce que vous pourriez en
ce qu'on pourrait dire aussi c'est que
l'admiration là serait vue comme une
emprise et que même temps que je ne
déçoivent pas que je fasse ce qu'ils
attendent de moi pour ne pas le décevoir
et bien je préfère le décevoir
et je me permettra de venir de saluer
les critiques qui font cet exercice
parce qu'ils n'ont pas le dernier mot et
ça les critiques n'aiment pas toujours
et je trouve toujours courageux pourront
inquiéter de livrer à sakété et de vous
laisser le dernier mot ou la fin du jeu
le effectivement je le remercie pour ça
il dit que c'est au moins vraie critique
quelqu'un qui sous sa parole
alors on parlait de bad love de
catherine breillat qui répondait à une
critique de pierre vavasseur du parisien
voilà et on attend l'adaptation en film
tellement désolé si je vais peut-être un
peu un pain mais lui aussi cette écoute
griffes aussi une grille fait beaucoup
dans son nom mais c'était très bien
quand j'ai trouvé que vous trouvez ça
casse
voilà
[Musique]